hey everybody the star wars cassian
andor series
is coming to disney plus there's a
sizzle reel that came out
at disney's investor day they gave us a
deeper behind-the-scenes look at this
series it's gonna follow
diego luna's character uh from rogue
one he was a rebel we believe fulcrum
agent uh it was kind of like an
espionage
series that was set up there on the
rings of caprine
uh that could have been a whole series
we agree and now so did lucasfilm
eric voss here i'm back with screen
crushes ryan airy kim trung
and kristen sanchez we're going to talk
about everything we know about this
cassian andor series
it's going to be a 12 episode prequel
series 12 episodes is interesting means
they got a lot of story
to dive into we learned that amman
mothma is going back genevieve o'reilly
is coming back from rogue one she's
gonna be playing her role as the
political leader of the whole rebel
alliance
um i assume going to be the uh judi
dench
m2 d luna's bond character right
what have you got yourself mixed into
again
um we got to see some concept art uh
showing cassie and endor and
other rebels it looked like they were
playing some kind of mission to blow a
dam
uh which i love because i don't know
about you guys the recent episode of the
mandalorian i thought
uh bill burr was going to wreck that
damn and flood that whole village
you can't blow up explosive crap on a
dam
and not have it gush water everywhere a
missed opportunity maybe they're saving
that visual for
this cassian edwards series also in this
shot there is someone in an imperial
officer uniform standing right there
which maybe that's like a mole they're
gonna be like all right
you're gonna be pretending to be
imperial and you're gonna go in there
and he's like okay great
i uh this uniform used to have a dead
guy in it so it kind of stinks
um but uh it also kind of shows maybe
this we're gonna see the very first time
someone posed as an imp to go behind uh
enemy lines which is something they do
in every star wars story now um
but this could have been the first time
it happens i would have fun but i think
what i'm most curious about
are the ways it's gonna tie into what we
already know
so like we're watching the mandalorian
they have boba fett and ahsoka tano
showing up on there
there's going to be some connections and
crossover between this cassian andor
series and things we've already seen
so from you guys i want to hear what
character storyline do you think
from the extended star wars universe uh
things like rebels or clone wars from
from rogue one the movie that's gonna
happen after this
uh the the prequel movies whatever how
do you think it's gonna tie into the
cassian and or series what is it gonna
be how is it gonna connect
uh kristen what do you think here's what
i think i
really think that they are going to take
a
dark turn with this series um so a lot
of our star wars
world is in this like place of like pj
pg-13
where we all feel very comfortable and
everyone's included and it's great
but we haven't really had a like r
series that is star wars yet and this
i know i know go with me here maybe it's
not gonna happen but it's what i want so
we're gonna play with it
okay so um so we're going to get like
this like
real dark gritty series because in that
like
big speech that he gives um right before
they go and they do
like everything that happens in rogue
one and um like
all of that they have that like moment
where he's backed up by all of those
people that are like we've done
some [ __ ] for the rebellion
like we have made some bad choices
and like at the end of this series like
i want to
question the validity of the rebellion
i want to question why it happened and
like i want
i want everyone to be like oh my gosh
like who's really the right
side of this because of all the
decisions that they made but i think
that would be
like really really interesting and i
would like to see that
and i think it'd be great to have those
characters all come
from like originally rogue one and be in
that series and like maybe he goes on a
couple of missions and we see those
people again but like yeah that's what i
want i want a dark series i want a
gritty series
and i want it now no yeah i mean
what you're describing kim uh kristin is
like exactly
what uh i i think we all felt after
rogue one
you know that kind of sense of uh the
fog of war mixed morality
um that like these people are terrorists
if you think about it i mean they're
terrorists
yeah with a good cause you know bringing
down space nazis
but the things they're doing like uh
cassie and endor in that scene on the
ranks of katrine he he kills a guy or he
gets a guy killed and it's implied that
he's done a lot of that
uh so absolutely i want the series to
explore that darkness of a
the the rebel alliance aren't always
these uh shining uh
you know war heroes and these freedom
fighters
they've done some dark things in the
name of that freedom so i think that's
definitely totally
we'll explore they're the good guys but
like how how good are they really
yum thanks for being energy for
sponsoring this video
every can of bang is 16 ounces it
contains 300 milligrams of caffeine whoa
it's sugar-free and it has zero calories
yet it tastes
really good bang
there are over 20 different flavors to
choose from one of those great flavors
is
cotton candy do you know what cotton
candy is it's just a cloud of sweet
this is what it tastes like if that
cloud were to just rain a sip in your
mouth
that sip turns into a carnival that
keeps you moving on all day long
check out bang on instagram you can get
off your order at bangenergy.com when
you use the code newrockstars25
there you can buy cans of bang energy
including their sweet tea ketu coffee
flavors
bankster berry purple guava pear star
blast
pina colada there's all kinds of great
flavors you can also get clothing
fitness supplements all kinds of stuff
to be your best
bang self thanks again to bang energy
for sponsoring this video get 25
off at bang energy.com using the code
new rockstars25
kim kim i want to hear from you uh how
do you think this is uh gonna look what
are what are
gonna be the the characters the story
lines from uh
from the other series we've seen that
tie in what specific characters are
story lines
so i was like nodding and pointing the
whole time when kristen was talking
because i think we're
beating around the same bush but what i
love
about the mandalorian is this real
exploration
of good versus evil and how those lines
blur
and um in an improv
class one of my teachers said there are
no true villains and there are no true
heroes
and i want to see the exploration of
that
in the andor series through my boy
saw guerrera played by forrest whitaker
i want to see his beef with the alliance
i want to see
his extreme militant tactics i want to
see what breaks him like
what makes him tow this line because he
has got to be an antagonist i think
to cassian in in their in the alliance's
efforts in a big way
um and how how far will that antagonist
the role of his antagonist go i want to
see that
so bad it it's prime like it feels like
rogue one
well funny enough when i watched rogue
one i was so depressed at the end
because all i kept thinking was i'm
never gonna see these characters again
and i
love them so much and then the series
came out and i was like hooray
so of course naturally i'm like you
better bring my boy
saul guerrero back because clearly he
dies at the end of rogue one
um not the end of rogue one but in rogue
one and um
i wanna see him i wanna see him crumble
i want him
i wanna see him go from what may have
been a hero
to now a villain yeah a villain or at
least a thorn in the paw of the whole
rebel alliance he's over there on jedha
now he's just uh leading that group and
uh they're kind of like taking things
their own way
um boy do i want to see borg gullit uh
he better bring that
i want to know more about that weird
squid thing that forces you to tell the
truth and tortures you
yeah that was a thing that was a sex
thing i know it was a sex thing i want
to know
what they were really using bor gullet
for because that's then maybe you'll get
your
r-rated this is your r-rated show that
we're going to get
this is what we want i want that too
suddenly
if the hobbit can do it if the lord of
the rings can do it why not star wars
come on disney you know tony gilroy is
like we're not cutting
the borgulet stuff i know there's a
bunch of dicks on this thing but we're
leaving them in
you can't tell me to do it they're like
wait digs that brings it to nc17 he's
like i know fine
add another dick it's like he's like a
referee in like a high school basketball
games like
give him another foul shot and another
one okay
put another dick in there you want to
keep going what's the third deck for you
anything about this dick we are adding
three more dicks
i'm with you or no it's like the the
small town judge that like
judge morty's like all right fine two
more dicks
the punishment this video brought to you
by blue
[Laughter]
all right ryan um uh bring us back to
sanity but uh ryan who do you think
uh is gonna be the the other character
who ties in with this series
okay there's one character from clone
wars and rebels
every time they're ever on the screen it
just it makes the episode
they're a lot of fun i'm always like
anytime when rebels came out i was like
i really hate
really hope they go back and show this
character and that's hondo anaka
the pirate king from clone wars i love
hondo
he's the kind of guy who just loves
being bad he's always having a good time
he's a little bit of an anti-hero but
he's always like
angling for profit and we you know we
see him in clone wars he's still doing
fine then in rebels he's destitute we
never find out how
so i don't know exactly when this is
going to take place in a court like this
series is going to fall in the
timeline but i would love to see like
the downfall of hondo or him trying to
scrape his way back
because i think that these early days of
the rebel alliance like you're talking
about how they're basically terrorists
they're not necessarily going to be
enemies
with the huts and the gangsters and a
lot of times they're going to be using
them and that's going to like those
moral lines you guys are talking about
that's where those are going to come up
like okay we're going to use the huts
and these other gangsters to accomplish
but
the ends justify the means and then you
can have hondo in there
and if you're going to take you know
solo into it we can see what happens to
kira
if they can get amelia clark to come
back i mean i would like i don't think
they're going to make a solo sequel
so hondo can just lead the charge of all
these rogue characters
into into the cassian source series i
would love that
yeah i love that uh yeah hondo is is
really cool
and like he is one of these uh figures
from the animated series it's like can
we please get this guy in live action
and yeah now we finally
if it's if it's not if it's not cassie
and nandor series it's
it's got to be kenobi you know we get
him in one of these two
uh anto thai kenobi solo thanks
kenobi yeah yeah the uh all that stuff
from solo
i mean solo is such a weird movie but
man to get in crimson dawn to
potentially bring in maul
and kira in this that could be really
really cool i feel like maul would be
more likely to come up in the kenobi
series than
than cassie nandor which is dealing with
stuff like you know
weird alliances you have to make which
hondo is like perfect for that
i think that's a that's a great great
great direction this could go but uh we
want to hear from you guys let us know
in the comments below
uh what you want to see this series
being um
like do you want it to be more james
bond do you want it to be more like
jason bourne
espionage uh like how many people do you
want to see him kill how bloody do you
want to be do you want to be a hard
r probably not disney plus though it
does sound like disney is carving out a
little section on this platform that
could be for more mature
content is that where this is gonna go
uh
uh what kind of missions what kind of
details left over from rebels and clone
wars do you want to see uh comment down
below
but a big thank you to all of our guests
here uh ryan airy
kim trung kristen sanchez follow all of
them on their respective social medias
it's been a wonderful episode going deep
into the star wars universe with you
guys
uh don't forget to subscribe to the
rogue theory podcast feed
um so that you can get early episodes of
all this stuff stay tuned to the new
rockstar's youtube channel for this and
other shows
follow me at ea boss follow new
rockstars on all social media
and yeah subscribe to us here at new
rockstars and we'll see you next time
everyone stay safe out there
bye
[Music]
you